jean marc bonjour à vis de vous
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
alors tous les économistes considèrent
que les parle des français pourrait
servir de carburant à la reprise
le problème c'est que cette épargne à
partir aux français alors comment est ce
qu'on fait pour la récupérer d'abord
c'est vrai que les français en stocker
de l'argent beaucoup d'argent pendant
l'année 2020 il continue d'ailleurs
actuellement et ça dans des proportions
très importantes parce qu'ils ne
dépensent pas leur argent leur pouvoir
d'achat a été à 80% à peu près maintenu
grâce à la location du chômage partiel
le quoi qu'il en coûte finalement à a
profité à maintenir les contrats de
travail mais mais cet argent n'a pas
arrêté en partie dépensé parce que la
plupart des magasins ont été fermés
pendant très longtemps et que les
occasions de dépenser ne sont pas
énormes on ne peut pratiquement plus
voyager on ne peut pas faire de gros
achats
au total sur l'année 2020 la caisse
d'epargne a récupéré plus de 200
milliards d'euros
on pense qu'elles vont récupérer autant
sur 2021 alors là on ne compte pas les
comptes courants les bas de laine tout
ce qui a été un peu cachés sous les
matelas l'argent liquide
au total on devrait avoir faim de
pandémie c'est à dire fin de l'année si
tout va bien ou en gros un pactole un
trésor de 500 milliards d'euros alors
pour en découdre ça fait saliver tout le
monde et tout le monde réfléchit à ce
qu'on pourrait en faire quelles sont les
pistes et jean-marc il faut d'une façon
ou d'une autre
remettre cet argent dans l'économie vous
le disiez très justement c'est le
carburant de la reprise on va pas
pouvoir continuer à faire tourner la
machine avec la planche à billets c'est
à dire avec de l'endettement public
il faut absolument sortir de cette
impasse il faut récupérer cette épargne
il faudrait qu'elle aille de
l'investissement des entreprises et
surtout dans la consommation alors
premier point on exclut pour le moment
et ça c'est très officiel de faire des
impôts spéciaux qu'ovide un impôt
spécial convient d'ailleurs c'est une
idée ou vous-même un emprunt obligatoire
tenez ce qui reviendrait d'ailleurs un
peu au même c'est une idée qui est dans
toutes les têtes mais ça serait une très
mauvaise idée parce que ça asphyxierait
les velléités de reprise de l'économie
si vous payez imposait pas tellement
envie de continuer d'avoir des
initiatives d'innovation deuxième fois
on va essayer de flécher cette épargne
vers les entreprises pour qu'elles
renforcent leurs fonds propres
parce qu'elles peuvent avoir des
problèmes de trésorerie à la sortie de
crise
alors là il ya plein d'idées on peut
certes dû jouer avec des incitations
fiscales
il ya quand même un inconvénient c'est
que les français ont peur d'investir ils
ont peur d'investir dans les entreprises
ils ont toujours eu peur les français
ils préfèrent des placements moins
risqués ça vire type bons du trésor
obligations mais ça l'argent va vers
l'état vers les caisses de l'état et ça
ça me permet pas forcément de vivifier
l'économie troisième point via la
solution la plus utile c'est que c'était
pas mal dans la consommation
mais là encore c'est compliqué parce que
quand vous les français se mettent à
consommer ils ont tendance à acheter des
produits étrangers des produits chinois
par exemple donc si c'était paris sert à
faire tourner les usines de shanghai et
shenzhen ça profitera pas beaucoup à
l'économie française
et donc il va falloir qu à bercy on soit
malin j'imagine alors comment est-ce
qu'on est malin quand on travaille à
verser écoutez l'équation
ça se présente l'équation que doit
résoudre
bruno le maire est un peu compliqué mais
jusqu'à maintenant il a quand même été
assez cohérent 1 sur les mesures de
soutien les mesures de relance d'abord
un il faut que les français et envie de
dépenser leur épargne il faut donc
qu'ils y ait un climat de confiance est
là tout dépend du de la sortie tout
dépend du vaccin finalement y compris
pour la consommation et pour le
comportement personnel défense et
ensuite il faut que les français
achètent des produits français et de
préférence un made in france
et ça c'est plutôt bien parce que si ça
va créer de l'emploi
et ça va permettre de la de
réindustrialiser donc il faut
réindustrialiser il faut encourager ce
mouvement d'acheter français et puis il
faut enfin que les produits achetés
participent à la protection de
l'environnement ça veut dire des
voitures électriques par exemple ou des
logements sa faible taux de perdition
cela pour attirer les jeunes plutôt de
façon à ce qu'ils consomment le problème
c'est que les jeunes bien ils ont
beaucoup moins d'argent que les seniors
alors on va assister à des campagnes de
communication mais pas seulement
on va sans doute et ça c'est une idée
assez sérieuse qui circulent
actuellement à verser favoriser les
donations favorisent et les successions
ces donations et successions était
sévèrement durcies au niveau des
modalités fiscales notamment françois
hollande l'avait fait nicolas sarkozy
aussi avait un peu renforcé l'imposition
des successions on va sans doute libéré
tous à libérer tous à l'objectif c'est
que les l'argent circule d'une
génération à l'autre il faut que les
jeunes puissent être aidé pour acheter
un logement sans attendre
malheureusement la mort de deux de leurs
parents si leurs parents leur laisse un
peu d'héritage
on peut aussi faciliter les donations
pour ceux qui n'ont pas d'héritier et ça
c'est très important
il ya beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas
forcément des rites pied et qui
finalement est que cet argent est
dispersée un peu entre les héritiers
très lointain où l'état si l'on pouvait
permettre à des gens de donner de
l'argent en franchise d'impôt à ceux qui
en ont franchement ce serait là un
progrès ça permettrait de booster la
consommation des jeunes les jeunes
auront des besoins qui sont beaucoup
plus importants et beaucoup plus
spécifique de les seniors merci beaucoup
jean marc sylvestre on vous retrouve
avec plaisir mercredi prochain pour
l'édito échos de la matinale